[Applauso]
grazie a mio padre armeggia con il
computer fin da quando ero molto molto
piccola all'età di nove anni ho iniziato
a fare le prime grafiche elementari
poco tempo dopo già lavoravo su software
professionali ma solo recentemente ho
iniziato veramente a capire ogni
meccanismo dietro a tutto ciò che
creiamo
prima di allora buttavo giù idee
d'impulso non mi fermavo molto a pensare
sulle scelte che facevo da qualche anno
ho iniziato a interessarmi alla
questione del colore e della sua
percezione come la grafica possa
influire sulle nostre menti e sulla
nostra società
immaginate di trovarvi in una situazione
del genere
state per lanciare la vostra invenzione
sul mercato un'idea brillante ed è
arrivato il momento di scegliere la
veste grafica del vostro prodotto dalle
forme al colore ma il risultato non è
quello sperato
ecco in questo momento avreste voluto
avere qualche informazione sull'utilizzo
del colore nel marketing ancora più
banalmente dovete scegliere cosa
mettervi per un evento importante
un'occasione speciale come la mia in
questo momento e volete comunicare una
precisa idea di voi ecco anche qui
potreste aver bisogno di questa cultura
non è una cosa così scontata in fondo se
i personaggi pubblici pagano qualcuno
per farò il posto loro un motivo ci sarà
donne tutte noi sappiamo che al
matrimonio il bianco è prerogativa della
sposa
però a volte capita di incontrare
qualche coraggiosa che decide di
indossarlo comunque è lì partono i
commenti a volte positivi ma molto più
spesso negativi è proprio quello che è
successo nel lontano 2011 quando al
matrimonio tra william e kate la sorella
della sposa philippa middleton ha
indossato un lungo abito bianco è stata
molto criticata dalla stampa perché con
il suo bianco sembrava voler oscurare
che
ogni colore ha un suo preciso
significato che induce l'osservatore a
certi tipi di reazione
nessun colore è uguale un altro non
esistono colori intercambiabili ogni
singola nuance svolge un preciso ruolo
in passato la sposa non è sempre stata
bianca infatti per il lungo periodo non
vi era un colore preciso con il quale
sposarsi ma si guardava più alla
ricchezza dell'abito o ai suoi ornamenti
la prima donna a vestirsi di bianco le
proprie nozze sulla regina vittoria nel
xix secolo da quel momento in poi tutte
le donne si vestiranno di bianco o
meglio tutte le donne occidentali
infatti altre parti del mondo le donne
hanno mantenuto l'abitudine di vestirsi
colorata il giorno delle proprie nozze
in africa ad esempio le spose sono molto
variopinte in cina in giappone in india
sono vestite di rosso simbolo di amore e
prosperità volete ridere in oriente
il bianco non è altro che il colore del
lutto
[Applauso]
proprio come per gli abiti da sposa ogni
paese ha un suo preciso colore di
riferimento quindi ci stiamo rivolgendo
a un target quando lanciamo un prodotto
sul mercato per farvi un esempio quando
pensiamo all'oriente in particolar modo
all'india queste sono alcune delle prime
immagini che ci vengono in mente un
tripudio di colori colori caldi e vivi
che ci fanno viaggiare fin là in gergo
tecnico si dice che questi colori sono
colori saturi ovvero che hanno il 100
per cento di pigmento puro al contrario
in europa si preferiscono colori
pastello ovvero che hanno fino
all'ottanta per cento di saturazione in
meno oltre che una luminosità nettamente
maggiore pensiamo ad esempio al magenta
o all'arancio quelli nella prima riga
sono colori saturi
nella seconda colori pastello notate
come inviano due segnali nettamente
diversi al nostro cervello
vi faccio capire meglio pensiamo a
questa scritta india per un nuovo
negozio che vende
prodotti etnici passando per la strada
non voteremo mai un negozio che all
insegna del genere
innanzitutto perché noi italiani non
siamo assolutamente ad associare il
colore pastello all'india
le cose cambiano radicalmente se i
colori utilizzati sono saturi e vedete
come le parole passano in secondo piano
rispetto alle immagini
avete presente maggie smith in dantone b
nella maggior parte delle scene vestita
di viola non si tratta di un colore
scelto a caso bensì sta proprio a
significare nobiltà e ricchezza viola è
sinonimo di lusso infatti ha impiegato
da molti marchi famosi proprio perché ha
un colore davvero particolare dalle
infinite sfumature molto duttile
per farla breve non passa mai di moda ma
se per me occidentali viola vuol dire
ricchezza in cina è sinonimo di povertà
perché opposto cromatico del giallo
imperiale quindi potremmo presupporre
che un oggetto di lusso di colore viola
in cina non avrebbe successo quando si
lancia un prodotto sul mercato
bisogna sempre considerare il target
quindi è sempre opportuno fare uno
studio del mercato e dei suoi acquirenti
ancora meglio uno studio della mente del
proprio cliente
ora pensate a una bibita analcolica
frizzante di produzione industriale a
base di acqua zucchero caffé in acido
fosforico e coloranti alimentari non
avete capito ciò di questo parlando vi
faccio vedere un'immagine un colore non
serve aggiungere altro
questo logo vincente la nuance di questo
prodotto è inconfondibile tra milioni di
sfumatura questo marchio alla sua che è
unica e universalmente riconosciuta
questo ovviamente influisce sulla
notorietà del brand e sul fatto che in
breve tempo si è diventata una delle più
ricche e influenti al mondo
vedete come il colore sia importante
come il colore influenza l'economia
anche io mi sono ritrovata nella
condizione di dover creare un logo non
sono ancora diventata plurimiliardaria
ma ci sta lavorando insieme ad un gruppo
gli amici abbiamo messo in piedi
un'azienda fittizia
abbiamo creato una nostra applicazione
che permetteva di ordinare i pasti dallo
smartphone
un'applicazione come ce ne sono tante in
giro ma la nostra applicazione e serviva
un logo e mi è stato chiesto di a
realizzarlo
il primo nome che ci è venuto in mente è
stato elf ovvero un acronimo per elimina
la fila niente meno che lo scopo
dell'applicazione
inutile dire quanto fosse sbagliato quel
nome è anche tutto il resto
perché nessuno si sarebbe mai ricordato
di noi quindi abbiamo deciso di provare
un approccio diverso
ci siamo chiesti qual è lo scopo della
nostra applicazione semplificare bene
quali sono i colori che rimanda la
semplicità
ovviamente il bianco e il nero perfetto
ora che abbiamo i colori qual è
l'alimento più semplice di tutti il
grano perfetto il nostro logo era fatto
la spiga di grano che ha dato un tocco
di colore a tutto l'insieme il
cappellino i baffi sono venuti poi
questo è un luogo che parla da sé vuole
innanzitutto comunicare lo scopo con il
quale è stato realizzato l'applicazione
ovvero quello di semplificare la vita
quotidiana in più vuole anche far
rimandare alla sua semplicità di
utilizzo al fatto che sia rivolta a
tutti abbiamo presentato il nostro
lavoro ad un expo
al termine gli altri ragazzi ci dicevano
ah ma voi siete quelli di corna che bel
lavoro che avete fatto che cari le
grafiche insomma si ricordavano di noi
quando un colore è quello giusto
non c'è bisogno di altre parole per
descriverlo ognuno di noi ha in sé una
sorta di dizionario dei colori e tende
ad attribuire un significato ad ogni
colore che vede ed è impossibile poi
togliergli e lo di dosso è un po quello
che è successo con l'espressione inglese
aifil blu indica l'essere tristi o giù
di corda ma la sensazione non è dato da
una parola qualsiasi bensì da un colore
il blu che fonde proprio questo senso di
nostalgia ci stiamo allontanando dalle
parole per andare di più verso una
comunicazione visiva più efficace
universalmente riconosciuta e
riconoscibile
questo è facilitato ovviamente dalla
capillare diffusione della
tecnologia e del cosiddetto colore
facile ovvero quello che tutti siamo in
grado di proporre su degli schermi in
altissima definizione perché infatti
scegliere cartelloni pubblicitari così
ingombranti statici scegliere stampe
d'inchiostro quando possiamo proporre la
nostra immagine su un display più vivo e
strano a dirsi economico pare però che
la carta non sia destinata a morire
ancora vita lunga anche se è stata già
ampiamente sostituita in ogni campo
ripercorriamo insieme tutto quello che
ho detto fino ad ora abbiamo parlato di
bianco di nero di magenta di arancio di
viola ora concorderete con me
sull'importanza del colore per me il
colore è l'alfabeto del futuro
comunicare tutto ciò che hai da dire
senza limiti senza emettere fiato grazie
[Musica]
[Applauso]